good afternoon everybody how is
everybody doing thanks for joining the
stream here yeah we're doing it here
it's raining in LA right now I love the
rain it's very very peaceful today so
there's a couple announcements while
everybody's still rolling in here so the
discord channel here is actually taking
a little step up here because we got so
Demonte as a moderator and he's helping
out you know organizing this discord
chat and making it awesome and really
taking it to the next level here I don't
know much about discord and this is my
first time actually making a discord
channel so I just want to give a sudden
want a a shout out here and say thank
you so much for stepping up and you know
helping helping this go to the next
level here because it's really gonna
help bring everybody together you know
in a fun and organized way so I think
that's super cool thanks so much man
yeah we're working at it we got some fa
Q's going on here we got some rules
going we're gonna organize these chat
rooms here so if you have cinema4d
specific conversations or blender
specific conversations we can talk about
all that stuff you know in a more
organized way we got some emojis coming
yeah it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be
super sweet so thank you so Demonte for
doing that
guys I must admit I have no idea what
we're gonna do today like for the first
time maybe the second time have
absolutely no idea what's gonna go down
on this stream right now so you know
obviously I got cinema 4d open right
here and we're gonna make something I
know that some of you guys had asked
about lighting in the
stream suggestions or rather tutorial
suggestions a little bit here on the
discord and you know some of you asked
about lighting and how to light well
with spotlights and area lights you know
we can certainly talk about that it's no
problem but I'd like to ask you guys
here who are here live right now what do
you guys want to learn today what do you
guys want to talk about it is pretty
much open we're gonna go for the next
two and a half hours or so and we can do
whatever we want so let me hear it guys
what do y'all want to learn and also
really cool that you guys are visiting
this livestream from all over the globe
we have someone in what is it South
Africa someone from let's see where
y'all from Austin Austin you still live
in Atlanta
we got South Africa what else we got
guys we got Spain well hopefully
everyone's staying staying safe out
there because you know the coronavirus
is going crazy over the last week or so
so hopefully everybody's feeling good
inside ready to learn
we got Pakistan Argentina Croatia oh my
goodness this is awesome India Virginia
Portugal Sweden Spain Las Vegas Mexico
this is awesome what a this is an
international group here Germany Brazil
Poland Palestine Palestine Palestine
another India Trinidad dang this is cool
this is really cool all right so what do
you guys want to learn here underwater
scene potentially an underwater scene
okay
hmm play with some dynamics connectors
Springs motors that's always fun
let's see what else y'all what else what
should we do give me give me some
suggestions here drawing an octopus
making an underwater scene okay hmm I've
never done an underwater scene it'd be
interesting it could be very interesting
actually okay we got fluid simulations
octane tune shader
[Music]
what else y'all what else an exploding
head ooh I'd be rough keep the ideas
coming
okay Athens the lost city a sunken city
an abandoned train station I'm always
down for abandoned train stations
volumetric underwater lights let's see
something that shows my sick texturing
skills okay
I do love texturing I really really do
love texturing hmm-hmm-hmm projection
mapping on a track shot with some ground
shatter oh that's classic one it's
actually a really good idea car on the
forest road painted train station a
shipwreck what can we do in two and a
half hours I think we could certainly
set up an underwater scene in two and a
half hours you know some like coral reef
business going on some central subject
in the middle some floating something or
some like half buried something in the
sand with like a nice spotlight shining
down on the subject maybe I think that's
probably the best bet so far rain scene
with abandoned places ah I am a sucker
for abandoned stuff in the rain hmm
train station but there's a boat instead
of a train oh my goodness that's pretty
funny yeah just like a an old pirate
ship coming through the subway it'd be
awesome
coronavirus what would the corona buy my
girlfriend says no I was thinking about
something coronavirus related like
someone in a hazmat suit walking through
empty streets or something but that
might take a little longer than two and
half hours
Jay quar thank you thank you for joining
I'm glad you're able to catch one as
well I have no idea what we're doing
today but we're gonna do something and
we're trying to figure that out right
now we have a an underwater scene with
volumetric lighting with some like coral
and some subject in the middle or
something might not be bad okay
I'm gonna go with the underwater scene
for now I think that's a good idea
so if I were to sketch something out
yeah let's let's get something out let's
open up Photoshop real quick and see
what we can do here I want to keep it
simple but it'd be cool to tackle the
volumetric lighting to eat you that
underwater kind of feel you know we can
talk about some sort of like spotlight
down on a central subject and we can use
like cinema 4d scatter or octane scatter
for coral and stuff and maybe some fish
in there
okay let's actually let's try this again
let's go 4,500 what's going on here what
Oh 4,500 by 3k and just a random like
quick tip so I learned through a very
very skilled photographer someone I look
up to very much that was his name's
actually marketed word Harris he's a
fantastic photographer I actually did a
podcast with him on the corridor podcast
and he I took his class at Sammie's
camera and one of the things I learned
from that class was as a photographer
you want to keep your aspect ratios the
same throughout your portfolio right you
don't want different aspect ratios it
just doesn't look as good so I took that
and I ran with it
and basically everything I post on my
Instagram is it's all photography at
this point it used to be lifestyle stuff
and just ran them whatever but all of
the photography is a 3 by 2 ratio so
that's why I just did a 3 by 2 scene
right here recently I've done some like
16:9 widescreen shots but other than
that it's usually on the 3:2 aspect
ratio so if you guys are looking to keep
your portfolio clean try and keep your
aspect ratio of all of your images the
same and it look nice and nice and clean
hello from Kazakhstan gooo view welcome
ok what does the underwater scene gonna
look like currently I'm using my my
mouse right now because the latest
software update on the little pen tablet
kind of jacked it up so let's figure
this out so we definitely want it to be
let's see you know something something
like this maybe and in the middle there
will be something here I don't know what
yet maybe it's like a sword or something
or in the sand I I don't know but
basically we're gonna want to have a
large like volumetric light come down
from the heavens and light our scene
that's not right and light the scene
here
so I'm just doing a sketch it's rare
that I do this but in this case you know
this makes sense basically something
like this with maybe it's very plain
it's very plain we could have like
scattered throughout like a bunch of
like you know coral reef stuff going on
in the foreground this is supposed to be
coral guys I don't really know what
coral looks like right now just kind of
like sea grass in the foreground maybe
there's like steps leading up to this or
something you know and I'm certainly
open to all of your guy's suggestions
here so I will be reading the comments
to see you know what y'all are
suggesting for this image but muskrat
Mike welcome he has a question just
curious about people how are our people
handling situation what does corridor
digital stance what actions you guys
taking for all what's going on again
weird question not a weird question I
think it's relevant question so in LA
you have different different businesses
closing down people working from home
and whatnot so today is obviously
Saturday this kind of went down all this
week half of the guys were in San
Antonio filming so Monday come Monday
we're gonna actually figure out what
we're gonna do if we're gonna work from
home for each or if we're just gonna
stay working at work it's a very small
group so we'll see but yeah I mean like
there's a lot of a lot of people rushing
to the grocery store and cleaning out
the shelves they're at a chicken we try
to get some chicken or out of that out
of toilet paper and you can definitely
tell that like people aren't really
going outside I've been going out but
maybe this next week we'll see we still
we'll see how things progress but uh
yeah now they shut down the NBA I was
supposed to go to a basketball game on
Monday first basketball game I've ever
been to or would have ever been to and
they closed that down so that's a bummer
but it's all for the best so yeah we'll
see how it goes down hopefully all you
guys are alright and what kind of vibes
are going on for this stream guys we're
making an underwater sequence today
we're talking about volumetric lighting
and how to get that like foggy you know
that foggy lighting or you know volume
it's volumetric lighting it's basically
lighting through fog you have where you
can see the light you can see the shape
of the light shining down on your
subject so we're gonna be doing a little
bit of that and I've never done an
underwater scene before so this will be
interesting
we're gonna have some stone steps here
with some sort of you know subject in
the middle I don't know if it's gonna be
a statue or a sword or a robot maybe or
something I have no idea
there'll be some coral in the foreground
and then as far as the background goes
I'm not quite sure yet maybe some like
rocks or something but we'll see yeah we
shall see and yeah um yeah let's just
jump let's just jump in let us jump in
so this is basically it you know I think
we can start setting this thing up so
the first thing I'm gonna want to do is
set my ground here we have like a little
sandy sandy patches here and then I'm
gonna want to find this like this pillar
here that our subject will sit on top of
so let's see if we can't find that on
mega scans dot-com it's my go-to website
for anything 3d they have the highest
quality you can always count on the
quality with this place over at this
site oh man they came out with some
sandbag barriers
yes oh man these guys the best so I'm
just gonna do a quick search under 3d
assets for let's see I'm gonna do a
quick su some chains would be cool maybe
let's do a search for stairs if they
have anything like circular that would
be nice
is this it that's it well shoot
okay maybe what we'll do is make our own
stairs maybe let's take another look I
bet you they have something like this is
kind of in the vibe some old ruins
putting a statue up here would be pretty
sweet
alright we're kind of getting into the
zone here with this right here well
let's keep going and see what they have
yeah let's follow Sun amante's advice
here and just search for pillar
hmmm I think this guy would be a good
start because we can actually duplicate
this a couple times so I'm gonna log in
and download this and then let's um
let's set up our our our ground plane so
we'll grab a texture for sand and then
we'll start to we'll lay our camera down
and we'll lay this pillar down and start
to get a feel for like the overall
general feel of the setup and the goal
here is to start as general as possible
and then work our way into the detail so
we want to get the lighting down we want
to get the feel down and then we'll
start doing the micro stuff um and you
know every stream I got a shout out the
playlist here so I put together like a
ambient playlist for you guys it's in
the description of this video right now
it's a Spotify playlist you can that's
what I'm listening to right now on the
little bone phones right here and it's
just super peaceful music to do some VFX
too and hang out so while I download
this you guys can check that out alright
sweet okay let's bring this model in and
you get prompted with this dialog box
when you bring in any new model and
usually all this default stuff is pretty
good here but what I'll do and what I
want to make sure of is that the up axis
is set to Y and sometimes that'll change
depending on the model you bring in and
sometimes that'll change depending on
the program you're in so you just want
to make sure that the up axis for the
program you're in is is correct and the
model will come in correctly and it'll
look nice so we'll load that here render
our scene and you know we've done this a
million times before I'm gonna make an
octane glossy material drag and drop it
on the model here and we're gonna go in
and you know drop our pictures into the
appropriate channels here so we have a
diffuse pass we have a normal map and a
roughness map and that should be good
for what we're doing here I don't think
we're going to need much more so there's
our diffuse
in our normal and normals going to give
you all that good detail and our
roughness which controls the amount or
how how spread out the reflection is of
your object here yeah there it is we
could go one more step and let's just do
that for the sake of this thing yeah and
drag in our displacement map here and
that is going to actually physically
displace the geometry of this model so
if you look here on the corner and when
we put the place displacement map on we
should get some extra detail boom now it
looks all chunky and gross there so we
didn't need to change our settings first
I'm gonna set the mid level to 0.5 and
that basically evens out what what
geometry gets pushed up and what
geometry gets pushed down it's gonna
it's gonna happen from the midpoint so
you'll get something like this versus
like you know everything going like this
and then we'll do height let's just sit
at the point want to see what that looks
like okay and we'll set it to set it to
5 centimeters and let's take the level
of detail up to like 4 K and that should
give us some more detail and you'll see
if I take this on and off we will store
the render buffer and let's take that
back up to 5 centimeters you guys can
see the difference in detail that it
gets us so that's physically displacing
the geometry of this model and it looks
a lot better to me cool so we'll save
this and let's make a new scene we can
turn off the comparison there
and let's let's lay out our ground plane
here so there's a whole bunch of
different ways that you guys can do that
in whatever program you're using whether
it be cinema 4d or blender or 3ds max or
Maya yeah appreciate you guys appreciate
you guys coming into the stream here for
any of those people who who are just
joining we are making an underground or
not an underground we're making an
underwater scene here something
something like this with like a little
pedestal in the middle with a sword or
some sort of subject with some like
foggy volumetric lighting coming down
onto the subject that's what we're doing
today so let's set our ground plane up
and make sure our scale is right so I'm
gonna spawn just a figure here and in
c4d the figure the height is basically a
little under two meters so this person
is basically already set to an average
height so that it gives me a good sense
of what the scale is gonna be and we'll
put them as the subject for now let's
hold down the little cube box here and
these are all of our primitives in
cinema 4d and if we go over to the
bottom right and you see the landscape
we can do some really cool stuff with
this now certainly you can do this with
a plane and and displacement maps but um
like noise maps and whatnot but this is
actually a really cool way to control
our ground plane here we can scale this
way up so if I go to the top left here
and I select a little model box here I
can use these uh these little points
here and push and pull and stretch the
geometry so let's just do this let's
make it pretty large and we'll want our
camera to be somewhere
you know here-ish lined up and centered
if we make it like a let's see select
our camera let's go with just like a 50
let's render our scene okay obviously
we're not underwater we are in some sort
of stairwell here so ctrl shift Z to
undo camera moves if you guys ever get
stuck in cinema 4d let us save our scene
because that's the most important thing
here don't want to lose our work
okay so before we texture the ground
let's see if we can't get the lighting
right so let's see here for whatever
reason I'm kind of feeling like taking
the ground plane and kind of just
curling it up on the sides so I'm gonna
hop out of the camera view here and see
if we can't use a bend modifier to do
that so I'm gonna hold down shift with
the landscape selected and Bend is
actually the first thing we see here and
I've never had luck with this thing like
I'm I'm very confused when I use it so
maybe whoa that's crazy
okay so it's pulling our it's bending it
wow that's actually pretty cool that
looks like a crazy wave or something if
you gave it like a water texture it's
awesome anyway I basically want to like
talk oh this thing you know
so let's give it a little bit of that
and I think there's a way to like there
it is yeah to rotate the modifier so
we'll go 90 degrees on that and you see
how it's there it is it's kind of
bending this thing will go to 90 degrees
the angle will keep at zero and then we
will rotate this another is it gonna
work like that 45 degrees I'm gonna undo
that let's say um let's crank up the
settings there it is there it is so I
just cranked I believe the y-axis for
the bend and that's going to give us
like a nice nice curve there
[Music]
I mean if you take landscape and then
rotate it 45 degrees your object
coordinates here landscape coordinates
and we rotate it on the right axis I'll
find the right one eventually negative
45 degrees and that way it kind of lines
up so now what we need to do is just
let's Center the axis on this thing so
we can have better control over it so
I'm gonna select the landscape and let's
see if this worked it's the center axis
to tool that does not work so let's see
if the axis Center tool will work
instead so I'm gonna click that and you
get prompted with this little dialog box
and for those of you guys using c40 and
you're not gonna be able to find this
because this is a custom button I
dropped in here if you hit shift C you
can type in axis Center and you can
either drag it up into here to make a
little custom button or just click it
maybe at the double-click it yeah you
get prompted with this little box
basically if you just with default
settings I'm gonna hit execute didn't
work so let's check the point's center
box here and try execute again still not
working let's include children and
execute still not working
let's try use all objects and execute
something happened but it wasn't what we
wanted so I'm gonna undo that
access to object to maybe it's cuz it's
not it's not editable that's probably
why it's because it's not editable so
let's um let's just manually move this
guy in place I'm hitting W to bring up
the move tool and I'm just gonna
position this guy just about just about
there and then let's um let's adjust
this this ground plane a little bit to
give us a bit more detail here so we'll
go to object and we'll start messing
with some of these segments here let's
do width and height width and depth
segments let's go 200 so give us a bit
more detail let's go a hundred percent
on rough and fine furrows gives us a bit
more detail scale
what does let's scale gonna do
interesting sea level okay plateau level
so I'm just gonna messing with this
stuff to see what see what looks cool
see what works let's bring this down a
little bit and I'm hitting s to snap
whatever I have selected to the viewport
I still think it's a little much so
let's um take the the furrows down let's
go like seventy five 275 fifty fifty can
I save the scene
maybe we can duplicate the landscape
here so I'm holding down ctrl and
dragging out let's delete the bend for
now go into this new landscape let's hop
out of camera view by clicking this
little crosshair button
and let's see if we can't just like add
I'm gonna undo the rotation and let's go
let's go 45 in the opposite direction
maybe 35 and position it just on the
side here and let's use this one and
scale this let's see let's scale this up
so we have a bit more detail on the
sides hop back into camera view and yeah
you have a little bit of detail right
there and I think it's gonna be nice
when we texture it and it's gonna fall
off into the fog and i am i think i'm
gonna use fog here because that'll give
you the same effect as being underwater
i believe at least holding down control
dragging and then hit our for rotation
and just kind of rotate this into
position move it back something like
that I like that that's that's pretty
nice so let's see if we can't get the
lighting right cuz that's what we were
trying to do I get sidetracked a lot
it's gonna happen I promise but let's
get this lighting down everybody doing
right bone along okay
okay so yeah we could use the mesh poly
brush and kind of push and pull polygons
as needed I'd say that it would be a
like a a micro detail right now so we
still want to stay as macro as possible
as general as possible and then we'll
work down into those details but that's
a good suggestion you guys have any more
questions everybody follow along and do
it okay
all right so lighting how are we gonna
do this let's see I kind of feel like
instead of an image it's gonna be more
of a color so I'm just gonna start from
scratch I'll delete my octane sky and we
just have you know it's just gray I'll
make a new one in HDRI environment and
if you don't have the custom buttons set
up basically in your and if you are
using octane you can basically go to
materials
I lied you can go to objects and right
here is an HDR I environment and that's
what I made right up here and you're
basically given two options you have the
ability to use an HDRI image which is
this like blue half sphere here or on
the left if you click that it's gonna
give you the option to just do a color
so that's what we'll do and we'll make
it let's go to Google real quick and
let's look up underwater scene and these
are a little too bright for my taste you
know this is kind of getting into in
terms of color kind of the vibe oh but
there's that uh
what's the like underwater statues this
thing
this is crazy yeah this is a really
interesting look here this is kind of
the color I'm going for with like a
grayish blue up top and like a turquoise
down down below that feels about right
to me so let's try and get that nice
gradient right there yeah and you see
how the detail falls off into the
background that's what the fog will kind
of do for us and when we shine a light
down through here it'll give us a nice
volumetric look
all right so maybe what we need to do
here is set our octane sky to that color
and I wonder if you can just use the
color picker here I doubt I doubt it's
gonna transfer over boom oh my goodness
it does ha that's great
sweet ok and then let's just make a save
and let's take an area light I'm gonna
rotate it 90 degrees bring it up top way
up top actually I'm gonna get out of
camera view zoom out here bring it up
and then let's actually let's make this
larger so it's really encompassing the
entire area let's go back in obviously
that's way too blown out way too intense
so we're gonna take the power down to
like 10 let's try 1 and I still want
that spotlight kind of look so maybe
what we need to do is kind of walk that
back a little bit I'm gonna hit T and
that's gonna bring up our scale option
here and I'm just gonna scale it back
down hop back into camera view and let's
take that light and set it back to like
30 power maybe 15 this is this is good
enough for now and we want that like
turquoise look right for for the bottom
so let's let's bring that image back up
and in the little dialog box here for
the light I'm gonna scroll down and use
light color does that work
if I check that I believe the easiest
way the easiest way to change the color
on the light is to go to texture and
we're going to go down to plugins see 40
octane and load an RGB spectrum and that
you should be able to control yep the
color of the light so with this little
dialog box here or this color swatch
picker thingy we're going to pick this
turquoise color here and that should
indeed give us the kind of vibe we're
looking for Oliver welcome we're making
an underwater scene today we started out
the stream having no idea of what we
were gonna do but it's an underwater one
today we're gonna talk about how to use
fog to make it look like a kind of
volumetric gross water kind of look I
just pulled up this reference right here
and we're gonna use this to kind of base
the scene around a little bit and you
can see here it actually looks like they
threw up some underwater lights because
these guys are all lit from the right
side unless I don't know unless the Sun
is coming from that way I have no idea
but it definitely looks like there's
some lights hitting this thing
interesting and here's another thing you
see this fall off this like this ramp
from this turquoise or from this blue to
this greenish color that transition I
definitely want to get that as well so
maybe maybe these mountains on the side
I don't know we'll see maybe that will
be something we walk in as we continue
the look here
and if you see your light and you don't
want to see it in the renderer all you
have to do is click the little area
light tag go to visibility and uncheck
camera visible
okay so now let's just grab our fog real
quick so basically the fog is going to
allow us to to have that fall-off that
underwater look everything's not clear
underwater so that's what the fog is
gonna do for us all right so while I set
up the fog if you guys have any ideas
for the subject of this scene right now
we basically have an idea for a pedestal
with like a sword in it which I'm not
the biggest fan of it's pretty generic
the statue the underwater statues are
pretty sweet like this this is awesome
and maybe we'd be able to cover it in
like you know some some greenery or
something and then we can talk about
like caustics here and caustics our own
it's like underwater lighting and how
the light gets broken up like that and
we might find out a quick workaround
like cheap method of doing that but if
you guys have any ideas for the subject
of this scene start let me know in the
comments here and we can we can take a
look hey pub G octane fog is not that
complicated let me show you it's
actually pretty simple so check this out
if you go to objects and you roll on
down here to octane fog volume let's
make one of those you get this box this
black box here and the scariest part
about octane fog is that it will wreck
your system if you're not careful
because it's very render intensive
so basically let's just pause the
renderer for a second let's get out of
camera view and zoom up into this box so
with the volume selected I'm gonna hit s
and that will basically snap the
viewport to the object you have selected
so we'll zoom on in here and you see how
it's basically in the viewport it's a
bunch of different cards like this
broken up into different you know
subdivided like this right and this is a
very tiny area we have if we want to do
this to our entire scene you know that's
gonna it's gonna be pretty intense for
the viewport alone so one the first like
the first thing I do when I bring in an
octane fog volume is I'll select the fog
volume and I believe it's under generate
yeah okay so the voxel size you have
voxel size in the editor and then you
have it in the renderer so for the
editor it's set to five by default and
let's just see what happens if I set
this to four it's going to get more
detailed you think that a number going
lower means oh there's less detail or
not as render intensive let's go to
three and let's go to two and as soon as
you set that to one your computer might
explode you can see how it's chopped up
a whole bunch here so we want to go the
opposite direction the first thing I do
is I set it to 100 and right away you
just get one card and it's gonna be a
lot easier to navigate around your
viewport and when you start clicking
these little these like little triggers
and start pulling these you'll see that
it's broken up and a lot more of it's a
lot safer right you're not gonna crash
your system and and again we're just
talking about the viewport not in the
renderer itself so let's just kind of
set this up so that this volume of fog
encompasses our entire scene and you
don't have to go way into the background
you don't and also notice you see the
fog behind the camera that stuff counts
too you know like that's taking up
computer juice all right so you're gonna
want to move this so that it's right up
in front of the camera and again you
don't need to go that far into the
background I'll go a little further
scoot it up so we're making the most use
of our fog here so right now it's like a
low-lying fog and we're gonna want to
scale this up and once again be aware
that you know you're trying to get it up
above the camera and out of view of the
camera keep in mind that you have all
this lower fog here that's below your
camera and it's still being computed so
you're gonna want to use that right you
only want to use as much fog as you need
so I'm gonna bring this up right just so
that's right on the ground there and
that should actually be plenty for our
scene you can set the fog size in the
editor to 200 even if you'd like you
know but ultimately once I get it set
and I feel like it's in the right place
of course I'm gonna save the scene and
then I actually hide the fog volume from
the viewport itself and it's really easy
to do that so basically in most programs
I know a lot of you guys are using other
programs in most programs you're gonna
be able to hover over something and it's
gonna show you what it does so if I
hover over this top little circle here
next to the volume it says volume object
volume okay it doesn't tell me anything
okay yeah it doesn't it doesn't tell me
anything at all so in that case you
start messing with stuff so this top
little light if I turn it if I click it
once it turns green that means no matter
what it's always gonna be seen in the
viewport the top light is for viewport
the bottom light is for the renderer
okay so if I click it one more time it's
going to turn red
and that means it's not deleted it's not
gone from your scene it's just turned
off like leader a little eyedropper it's
turned off that way we can navigate our
scene a lot easier you know
and same if you don't want to see this
like you know this bend modifier right
here I wonder if we can just do the same
yeah we just turn that off in the
viewport and you can see a little bit
easier so yeah let's hop back into
camera view and let's unpause our scene
and see what happens here
let's rerender it okay there you go the
fog is way too thick that's what's
happening it's just darkness so let's
select our fog and let's go I believe to
medium right and in medium you have you
have this little white box here and
there's a it's a volume medium load it
into this channel let's click that once
and here you are with your fog options
this is how you control your fog here so
the density is set to 100 right now it's
far too much even if you go down to 50
it's still gonna be far far too much I
usually go down to 1 and in this case 1
is still too much so let's try point 1
okay now with 0.1 you're starting to see
something so that's that's great and you
already have this volumetric effect
happening from up top here and I know
that's something we're gonna need a
change because the light here you can
actually see like this square look of
this light we want to have more of a
global top-down effect on our image here
so
you know this amount of fog actually
doesn't feel too bad to me I'm gonna
scoot it back cuz it looks like it might
be missing just the foreground I could
be wrong let's take the fog volume let's
go to our top view and just move it back
a little bit yeah that looks about right
I don't think it changed much as pretty
normal
save the scene and you know fog takes a
lot longer to render so that's just
something you have to deal with if you
have more graphics cards then obviously
it's gonna go a little bit faster but
you know just got to be patient be
patient with it it it totally totally is
worth it for that atmosphere so
everybody following along so far
everybody feeling good give me a little
thumbs up in the in the chat here
oh my goodness Squidward's house if it
was like a super dramatic a super
dramatic interpretation of spongebob
that's really funny actually that's
really really funny like an old
pineapple house or something or
Squidward's old house just like a like a
dilapidated broken down Squidward house
that's pretty good
you guys are awesome heck yeah
everyone's doing great dude we got 132
viewers right now
that's the most viewers that we've ever
had on the stream heck yeah you guys are
great everyone's staying inside keeping
healthy CG studio asked what GPU I have
what graphics card I have I have a 1070
I believe yeah I have 110 70 I would
love to get you know a better graphics
card at work at corridor I have 220 ATT
eyes and it makes rendering a lot easier
and a lot faster but yeah the 1070 is
doing me right just one of them
actually first question da or Die how do
you say your name
it might be di it might be die who knows
but he asks why don't I use a denoiser
honestly I really enjoy the film grained
look I shoot a lot of film I shoot a lot
of 35 millimeter film and I love the
grain that it gets you so the D noise
are where sometimes it's the right move
you know it's the right thing to do in
this case I don't really use it it just
it smooths things out a bit too much for
me and when you have the ability to you
know just let something render over and
eight or something renderer when you're
gone why not just render it normally you
know why not just max out the samples
and have it go at least that's my
mindset with it right okay let's see if
we can't start to work in this look a
little bit more so the camera tab here
in octane you have the camera imager
option and usually by default this comes
unchecked we'll go ahead and check that
and you can load different Luntz and
color settings saturation levels and all
this and that so I'm gonna load the
response here is set to linear my go-to
is Kodachrome 25 I love the look and
feel of this color setting here and
let's set the gamma down to like alright
let's go up to 2.5 make it a little bit
brighter you know what
gamma should say the same let's take the
exposure up to like 1.5 1.75 you know so
we have a bit richer colors a little bit
deeper colors here and we can certainly
tweak all the color settings and stuff
as we get closer to the final image but
right now I'm feeling like the fog feels
pretty good let's actually go in here
let's go into the fog let's go to
absorption and scattering that was
another thing I forgot to tell you guys
about so the absorption yet to be honest
I don't know exactly what these two
things do specifically but I know that
they work together in how your fog
reacts with the light and everything so
absorption I usually go with a brighter
white so I'll set that to like a point 9
and I'll tab down across the board there
and I'm like it just makes things
brighter boom just right off the bat
let's just try point 8
and scattering we can just keep that at
point five and I know these can take
certain colors and change the color of
your fog and that might be a good way to
mess with the color a bit so while we're
on it let's just see what happens if I
take this down yeah that's gonna give us
like a greenish hue to everything so
mate that could be a way to get some
more color out of our scene and if we're
gonna reference that Google image we had
yeah it's more like a turquoise
foreground with a deeper blue background
and right now it's kind of just like one
color and I am colorblind but definitely
looks like kind of one color here so
let's see let's raise our camera up here
a little bit and what if we change this
to direct lighting was I look like path
tracing is always better okay for
especially for fog and whatnot but yeah
let's see what let's see what happens if
we change the color of this here let's
do like a let's try and go for that
turquoise vibe so that's too that's too
green
[Music]
and it's closer you know the background
should certainly be that that blue so
let's go back to our octane sky settings
and let's let's just crank up okay so
the saturation is maxed on this what if
we just take the color up a little bit
or the brightness up I'm sorry yeah
somewhere somewhere in here and then in
your camera tab here if you set the
saturation a little higher and start
messing with like your exposure we can
start to get something that feels oh man
that's awesome that feels right
and I'm just tweaking okay so then we
also have the light color here so maybe
we can take up the saturation and
brightness on the light as well as the
power and we're gonna go higher on the
light because we can obviously see the
light here because we are underwater and
we have this volumetric vibe going so
let's hop out of camera view and bring
our light up a little bit higher
and let's make it let's make it a little
bit brighter yeah okay what if we M what
if we just take our light off and we go
to our octane sky here and we turn up
the brightness of our background let's
turn the light back on so yeah all of
this like pushing and pulling of your
light intensity and the different colors
of everything involved you can mess with
this all day so I think right now we're
in a pretty good place to start working
on the ground let's uh let's get like a
nice sand texture going through here it
looks a little low-poly right now once
we do that let's start getting the
subject better situated and then we can
start working on like the detail
lighting like we want to do like a more
intense spotlight on this thing we can
also scatter stuff along the ground so
I'm still looking for any suggestions
you guys have for the subject of this
scene or any little ideas that's like
the that's the best part about this is
reading your guys and suggestions and
incorporating a lot of stuff you guys
helped me out on the last two streams
like immensely figuring out different
cool ideas to how to make the image a
lot better so really really appreciate
you guys yeah so let's get this ground
plane going
couple different options we can use
mega-mega scans and search for a sand
here surfaces and it's gonna be
something more along the lines of a
smooth sandy material versus um you know
like a chunky rocky situation so we have
like something like this this is not bad
we also have something like this which
is not bad at all or like this it looks
a little compact you know same here
maybe not that bad ooh a moon landscape
next time that would be sweet yeah I'm
down for that
but hopefully a next week next Saturday
hopefully if he's down excuse me guys
I'm drinking too much coffee here Ren is
gonna come over and we're gonna do a
really fun challenge where we're going
to you guys saw the Boston Dynamics
video that we did right so basically
what we're gonna do or attempt to do
next week on next week's stream is
recreate you know a little scene from
Boston Dynamics live for you guys and
basically have the robot playing beat
Sabre because Ren loves beat Sabre will
get Ren you know playing beats a we're
all crazy
and we'll record the mocap data and have
the robot playing beat Sabre and we'll
take it all the way from like the mocap
data all the way through to the
compositing so if you guys are down to
see that go liked this video leave a
comment or something and let's get amp
for that because I think it could be
really really cool we're gonna try and
do it in like two and a half hours or so
three hours tops
and you guys will see the whole process
like how to drop the robot in how to
render texture track the scene composite
the scene and me and Randall just
basically switch in and out of the chair
here and and do that for you guys so I
think that could be really really sweet
but yeah let's find that sand we got
free sand right here
desert sand honestly I don't think it
matters too much when it comes down to
the exact sand we want to use but let's
always check references always always
always check references and you can see
here it's a pretty smooth sand that's so
crazy look at this
all right
I think this is a good one here let's do
this
let's also grab some coral and stuff so
under 3d plants on mega scans they also
have I believe a underwater yep an
aquatic section submerged yes this is
what we want this kind of stuff here so
there's only a small little chunk here I
know they have I know they have coral
and stuff too I swear
let's just try let's try coral oh these
are all like cards basically you put it
on a plane and it's just like 2d cards
and whatnot I think we'll be good here
with our our aquatic pack
so we have ocean seaweed we can
basically download like three of these
and just scatter it along the ground as
much as we need
okay all right so the real name is
Andrew all right Andrew nice to meet you
thanks for being on the stream here okay
Melanie we got how about an Atlantis
scene with under with ruins underwater
we'll see that might be a little intense
for for the stream today because I do
have to be out and basically out the
door at three o'clock today so we'll see
here um Northern Light drone or dome
hotel but underwater looks super neat
like an underwater observatory that's
really cool idea super cool idea King
Arthur Excalibur and the rock not bad
Timothy today we're making underwater
scene and we're taking suggestions for
what the subject of the scene should be
so I'm all ears man I am all ears
um oh man Clarissa says wouldn't the
pattern of the sand be determined by the
depth and if currents can affect it
probably but we're not going that detail
here we don't know how deep this is we
just don't want to know it's got to look
cool coral and see we've looked nice
nice pop of color yep shipwreck from the
shipwreck scene yes yes sure bikini
would be pretty involved
maybe maybe next time when we have a bit
more time but let's keep going let's get
this sand popping off here so I'm gonna
make a diffuse material because I know I
don't want to bog down the system with
more info than it needs here because we
gotta got the fog going and I know the
the sand will probably not be very
reflective so let's find our landscape
our ground landscape here and let's up
the poly count and actually real quick
I'm gonna hop out of camera view and
basically do the same thing that we were
talking about but for the for the ground
here I'm gonna move it up just enough so
that the camera is only seeing basically
the camera is seeing all of the ground
plane and we're not wasting any detail
here when we make when we subdivide this
ground plane even more so let's go 300
by 300 and you basically need if you go
any less than that you just don't want
it to look low poly right so I'm just
trying to be clear and stay clear of
that let's take the octane diffuse and
drop it on our landscape and let's hop
in here and start dropping some images
onto this texture so let's see let's see
let's unpack the sand here and let's
drag and drop we got a normal we have a
displacement map and we have a color and
an ambient occlusion map so I'm going to
drop that down into the node viewer here
and this is our normal let's start with
our color pass yeah so let's drug drag
that into the diffuse and let's just
render a region here so we can see what
we're doing and let's turn off the fog
so that we can really see what's going
on and already it's not bad the scale
might be a little large and I think the
ripple effect that we're looking for is
probably going to be baked into the
normal map as well as the displacement
map so let's keep going
there is the normal map connected yep
and I think it's a little large we have
a displacement map let's save that for
last and finally we have an ami and
occlusion pass let's just set up the
ambient occlusion pass and that's
basically a black and white image just
like this that gives us a bit more
shadow in the deeper parts of the image
as you can see here right so let's just
load that in in case we need a bit more
detail in the shadows and we need we
need that the grooves to pop a bit more
so with my with my diffuse pass or my
color pass selected
basically what you want to do is like if
you're an after effects for example
right you had this image on top of your
color pass you would set this to
multiply right to get rid of all the
white and to leave the gray levels and
it's basically the same thing here in
octane or any other node viewer
depending on what program you're in
should be basically the same so we'll
find a multiply node we'll drop it into
there
and we will drag and drop the ambient
occlusion pass into the second texture
option and you control it basically with
the gamma here so if I bring the gamma
down it will get rid of the AO or if I
bring the gamma up it will make it more
intense as you guys can see down here
just by sliding that you get more detail
in the grooves and you're faking it it's
like a fake effect so let's just um set
that to just half for right now or in
fact let's let's turn it off and then we
can walk it back in as needed right and
then finally we have our displacement
map so I'm going to make sure I save the
scene here and let's add a displacement
tag here and you need this displacement
tag or this displacement node in between
your image and your actual texture
because this is how you control your
image in the displacement settings so
before I even pipe this in I know I want
to set the mid level to 0.5 let's take
the height just to 5 centimeters for now
and then let's take the level of detail
to let's max it out at 8 K I'm not sure
the image the image is what is the size
of this image it is an 8k image so we're
gonna set that to 8k let's drag it into
there and we should see some movement
down here it's very subtle it's very
very subtle but let's leave it like that
because I know this image down here it's
too it's too large so we're gonna have
to scale down the texture you can do
that in a couple different ways and
usually what I do is I would select the
image here click on projection and make
sure the projection is uniform
throughout I'll set it to box usual
but I know that with displacement maps
in octane and at communicating with
cinema4d it doesn't really work as well
as we would all like it to so I know
that I have to do it a different way so
we have all these images piped into the
right places and we have the texture
applied to our ground and let's do it
for the rocks as well and let's actually
take those rocks and set the segment's
to 300 by 300 I had both of them
selected I changed the settings across
both which is really cool thing c40 can
do so let's just highlight all these
textures here and let's set let's set
the projection let's leave it the same
actually and let's just say tiles let's
set that to 3x3 and already you can see
look at that it looks so much better
that is awesome okay that that might be
it that looks really good to me let's
try just for the sake of it let's try 4
by 4 yeah sure that's cool I think 4 by
4 is great that that feels really good
to me to be honest let's uncheck the
render region and let's turn our fog
back on
and under the fog settings so we can see
we can see like the edge here our
background we certainly don't want that
and our our sand down here is a little
too saturated in green we want to kind
of go more for this this look if I can
find it again yeah this look right here
and you have that nice fall off into the
background which is definitely what we
want so what you do a couple things
let's see what would I do I would let's
take this area light and let's just
adjust the color here so I'm gonna make
it brighter okay let's go to the camera
tab and let's set our saturation from
1.5 let's just set it to 1 for now I can
still see that line there's a couple
things we can do there to blend that a
bit more let's see it was turn off those
maybe yeah that's I think they're fine
for now let's take the fog volume let's
hop out of camera view let's turn it
back on in the viewer and let's move
this fog volume up a bit more so that it
like the fog trails off into the
background a bit more
and you don't have to have the fog right
in the foreground too much because you
know you're gonna see through it anyway
it gets more apparent as you go into the
background let's go to the fog volume
let's go to medium click that little box
and the density let's sit at the point -
that should start to blend thing a
little bit more I'm gonna render region
just a vertical strip so we can see what
we're seeing and already it looks like
that did the trick we still need to get
our colors right but that that
definitely blurred the foreground into
the background okay awesome awesome
awesome let's take the absorption let's
go more of a blue with it whoa that was
very that's very blue ooh okay we're
starting to get there and we're starting
to get there y'all you see there that
blue to the green we still want the
foreground to be a little brighter so
let's go to let's see
let's go to the octane light let's make
it even brighter here just the color of
it right that's starting to feel right
[Music]
that's not bad that's not bad at all
let's render the region with the light
right here so this vertical strip here
everybody doing okay bone along all
right
okay andrew has a question he says do
you know how to get away from this
visible tiling because I can't find
anything to get away from it in cinema
4d yeah actually there's a couple tricks
you can do to get away from this tiling
look that you're talking about
which is basically oh and real quick I'm
really happy with this lighting setup
here this feels right to me
so let's turn off render region let's
turn off the fog and let's talk about
this tiling that Angie is talking about
so if we zoom out and we look down and
our ground here and actually I can't see
the seam so be honest but usually here
um basically what he's asking is when
you have a large you have a large area
to lay a texture across usually like a
ground plane or something you can really
see the tiling on the texture and one
way I get around that is basically to
take the ground plane I'll duplicate the
ground plane and I'll rotate the ground
plane around let's see let's you'd have
to do it
so the bend modifier is messing with
that a little bit so in this case it
would probably be something along the
lines of you'd have the group you'd have
to group the that the two planes
together the two landscapes together but
let's just say real quick just for
demonstrations sake let's uncheck the
bend there let's get rid of these other
two right and you have this ground plane
and it might be tiling all right but I
can kind of see it it's kind of tiling
here but if you duplicate it all right
Andrew you duplicate that and you throw
a new texture on it it's a texture that
is kind of similar to your first texture
but it's a new that's a new texture okay
and you rotate it a little bit like this
and you see how like different parts pop
out
right you're gonna have you're gonna
reveal different little chunks from the
new texture you just put on and even
here with just the same texture applied
it kind of breaks up the feeling a
little bit more so I'm actually using a
bit of elevation with like the terrain
here like you can use a displacement map
for that or if you just use the
landscape object in c40 you have a
little bit of terrain like this right
you duplicate it you rotate it it's
either a new texture or in this case
maybe just the same texture and it's a
way to break up the visual kind of look
of your ground so that's one way to
really get rid of the tiling effect that
you're talking about another way would
be to let's see another way it would be
to get a little bit lower to the ground
so you're not looking straight down at
this ground it's tiling right okay
Cody what's up ma'am thanks for joining
the stream hope you're doing well
I hope you are staying healthy getting
away from that coronavirus but thanks
for watching I hope you are learning
something I hope we're all being
entertained here and hopefully it's
pretty chill all right so let's let's
figure out the subject of our image
let's grab the this little pedestal and
drop it back into our scene here let's
turn off the fog volume for a second hop
out a camera view and I just again I hit
s to snap the viewport to the subject or
to the model I have selected and it's
having trouble loading the images so I'm
just gonna refresh the scene to make
sure it's not that yeah yeah okay so
we're good so we have a cool little
pedestal thing here let's um let's take
the pedestal let's scale it up a little
bit and then make sure it's on the
ground plane there I'm gonna duplicate
it control C control V I'm gonna bring
it up scale it down and make sure it's
just sitting right in there to give us
that like stonestep feel I'm gonna
rotate it a little bit so we have a bit
of difference between these guys and
then I'm gonna do it one more time I
think hold control drag it up hit T to
scale it down hit R to rotate this guy
the other way and I think that gives us
a nice little pedestal look here so now
it's just what what do we want to put on
this thing you know I think the
Squidward house is pretty funny I kinda
want to do the squid house
but like a bunch of statues would be
super cool certainly what does God dang
it what does Squidward's house look like
can we model this quickly it's a very
easy model that's a very easy model we
basically have an hour can we model it
birdhouse in an hour
texture it cover it with moss have fish
swimming through it let's try that let's
try it hopefully it doesn't end up
looking like this okay it's good word oh
man we got to put like a bunch of
clarinets like broken clarinets on the
ground too okay let's do this what's the
easiest way to do this let's take this
let's save it I can't believe we're
doing this
save it to the desktop let's save our
scene let's make a new one I'm gonna hit
ctrl N and let's load a little reference
image back here so I'm going to make a
plane by holding down the cube here I'm
gonna hit R click and drag and hold
shift to snap to a 90-degree angle and
we hit W to bring up the move tool move
it back a little bit bring it up a
little bit and let's make a new material
drag and drop that material double-click
that material and under under the
diffuse tab let's load an image and the
image will load is the one we just
downloaded from old Google
okay let's try that again
what on earth why is it not working I
Wow I don't know how to save images from
Google guys this is bad let's try it
again
Squidward house a perfect Squidward
house
here we go all right that's a JPEG boom
we've got a Squidward house but the
dimensions are all weird because we need
to set the dimensions of the plane to
the dimensions of the image so let's
check the dimensions of that image real
quick 768 by 576 768 by 576 that is the
proper dimension of a squidward house
right there so let's go into front view
hit s and let's set our View mode right
here our display to just grout shading
and that way we can actually see what
we're doing let's make a person for
scale about yay okay
[Music]
we'll move the plane and scale it up so
that we get the right scaling this
thing's pretty big I'm gonna hit L and
move well I can't do that because it's
not editable
I'll make the plane editable by hitting
C okay
let's undo that and take the segment's
down to just one by one let's make it
editable editable now I'm gonna hit L to
move the axis down to the bottom center
of the door it's this tool over here the
enable access tool the shortcut is L and
that allows you to move the axis around
so we'll go back to model mode and we'll
just position this just so and we'll
scale it so the person is about a
squidward height all right so then we
have our size right so now we want to do
is
save it first save our scene it
basically really is the pen tool to just
model this thing let's set the plane if
we go to basic just click to x-ray that
way we can see our grid here and right
next to the cube button you have your
pen tool okay so I'm gonna hold that
down and the pen tool is what we want
yep and with zoom in here and we can
adjust these points later but we want
these two points we're gonna basically
trace half of it and then we're gonna
make sure these two Center points are
right in the middle at zero so let's
click there we want to make sure this is
a ninety degree angle so we can always
come back and adjust it but basically
I'm clicking on the corner and this is
definitely out of perspective so I'm
gonna basically meet it halfway about
there and then back boom right on the
center point now let's go back to the
Select tool let's make sure that these
two points are on the same x-axis right
we don't want them off-center we want it
to be flat so I'm gonna select both of
those I'm gonna hit basically the scale
button here and if I move the y-axis we
want to get it to let's let's deselect
plane here
let's get rid of the plane go back to
our spline and just make sure we have
those two points selected hit T for
scale and basically you want to move
this you can scale it so that it hits
zero on the y-axis so if you type in
zero you're gonna know that those points
are exactly in the same place on the
y-axis seven four nine point five to
nine and it's the same deal there so we
want this point to be on zero
it's just off so you set the X to zero
and we're basically gonna do like a
lathe rap here on this thing to give us
the shape just like that base point
there and we want that to be at zero
zero and we'll go to this point out here
we want it to be flat on the ground so
we'll set the Y to zero and now if we
take if we go into 3d view
here I'll select the spline will hold
down alt hold down our subdivision and
lathe we'd let go on lathe and boom
there we go we also could have just
scaled down a sphere or a cylinder a
little bit but hey we gotta learn
something new right so we got that real
subdivide it later let's hop back into
our front view let's hide the lathe and
let's bring back our squidward house and
these will just be cubes will just scale
cubes around to get us the look here I'm
gonna turn the x-ray on and I'm gonna
make the cube editable and I'm just
gonna scale this down
all right so it's about that I'm gonna
hold ctrl and move this over here okay
I'll hold ctrl again for the nose make
sure it's right there move it up scale
it up a little bit let's bring our lathe
back in so these guys are too deep so
we'll bring those down the nose will
bring out and we know that the bottom of
the nose is a little bit bigger so we'll
scale that up and we know that these the
ears are inset a little bit so we'll
just select the top polygon and bring
them in so that it kind of matches the
shape of the head
okay ooh
Milan thank you for the super chat
appreciate you brother guys that is a
super chat if you guys don't know I got
that enabled a few weeks ago it's a cool
way to communicate also with all the
comments and stuff it's a lot easier to
see because it you know highlights and
everything so appreciate you brother
thank you so much I hope you guys are
learning something
I hope we're all having fun and I hope
this is super chill for you guys oh yeah
alright we're doing the Squidward head I
feel like this is tough for me you know
I feel like I'm rambling the whole time
so I hope you guys are doing alright
let's keep going
so basically we'll add bevels to all
this stuff and get the geometry right
for all this stuff in a second but we
know we want the unibrow across the head
here let's take this point here bring it
in a little bit and then we have our
unibrow so let's select our lathe we'll
hit C we'll make it editable so it's
just one object I'm gonna hit K L on the
keyboard and that's going to give us
this exert layer cut tool here and I'm
just going to cut the little unibrow
into the side of this thing you will as
a loop selection with so with polygon
mode selected we'll select that and then
we want to extrude that out so I believe
that's MT as a shortcut yep or you can
right-click it and select extrude from
right and this little quick menu here
and we'll scale that up and out
fantastic
fantastic
all right so let's uh let's cut the door
out so what we'll do is we'll go back
into our front view and let's hide
everything besides the square root house
and let's real quick just do a little
pen tool on this door here so we can go
a little lower because we're gonna
bullying out this piece I'm gonna click
once let's see if I can't get yeah there
it is boom and don't close the spline
and let's just adjust this real quick a
little point mode grab the move tool and
just straighten that out
and for cemeteries sake we'll make sure
that is zero on the x-axis we'll make
sure that is what negative 90 and this
is positive 90
let's try 80 and negative eighty okay
and then we'll use an extrude function
here on this so if we select the spline
hold down alt and you hold down this
button here the subdivision surface
button inside you'll have the extrusion
so I'll let go and that gives us
basically this piece here with the
extrude tool selected here I'll go into
the object mode set that to 50 so it's a
little thicker maybe 60 okay and we're
gonna cut that out of the Squidward
building so we just want to whoop cut
that hole right there so I'm gonna use
Abilene
we call these not modifiers they're not
objects it's kind of like they're not
effectors you know there's something
there basically things they're tools
right they're tools to help you get a
little further on your model so let's
select the house and then we have the
extrude here so I'm gonna make the
extrude editable by hitting C let's
select the lathe hold down alt and with
this little instance but I'm gonna hold
that down let go on that that makes a
little bull object and I'll drag the
door just inside
all right so let's just let's chop up
this lathe here so we um gives us a lot
more polygons to mess with so I'm just
gonna hit that once actually know what
let's put it in subdivision surface here
looks real bad because we need to come
in here and make some edge loops to
define better to find this object
boom boom
looking good looking good so we're just
making these cuts to really define the
shape of this thing that's gonna give us
a lot more polygons to play with when we
want to deform this this thing and give
it some texture and shape and stuff so
I'm still gonna actually make some cuts
into this so I'll turn off the
subdivision surface so like KL for the
little edge loop click once we can set
that to 50% and then let's just start
adding I think that is plenty let's do
the same for up here we'll set it to 50%
and we'll just add a couple more cuts
perfect so we turned that on that gives
us plenty of space to work with
fantastic okay um now we just want to
even out
let's give again there's no such thing
as a hard edge right except you want
stuff to catch light it needs to have a
little rounding to it so this here let's
uh hmmm how we can do this without
getting everything else let's select
this let's group the bool object here
hold down shift and let's just give it a
little uh let's give it a little bevel
we'll check the use angle threshold
button and that's kind of doing the job
is it doing it to up here as well
I don't think it is it's exactly what we
want
fantastic so let's go like two
centimeters one point five is good let's
give it two subdivisions that looks
pretty good there's a little janky
that's happening down here so maybe if
we scale up the extrude it'll kind of
even that out yeah there we go
sweet that's our school birdhouse let's
just make sure let's make sure our ears
and everything are good
all right so let's sum we want to bevel
these guys here and we'll turn x-ray off
let's get in here
and let's go like two and two for the
offset and the subdivisions and then we
will give these cubes a bit more
polygons to work with so same deal you
know we can probably just for me to
subdivide this stuff yeah maybe we get
rid of the bevels and subdivide these
we're gonna need to make some cuts
what the heck was it I'm working
okay that looks good and let's just
subdivide this a little bit
sweet don't do the same to the other
and finally on the nose
sweet so this is ready - the door so
let's go - mega scans really quick and
I'm sure there is a circular door 3d
assets door is it huh well I guess
technically it is a wooden door and we
just slap that thing in there hmm
[Music]
maybe not under 3d assets I swear there
was like just a just a normal old door
that would work yeah the old wooden door
basically this or something
you know this this medieval door looks
pretty sweet so let's download this real
quick
all right oh of course we need the eyes
the little portholes but that'll be that
should be easy enough let's drop in that
door we just downloaded real quick
you guys know the drill on this stuff we
have done it more than once
all right now let's just let's cut this
thing up
all right it's all one one model here so
yeah we basically just want the door
nothing else so I'm gonna use the
rectangle selection tool and just start
selecting things and deleting actually
before I do that I'm gonna save this
asset because you know probably use it
later
now we go back and we start deleting the
stuff we don't need
should basically be basically be it
[Music]
a little quick cleanup on this
let's grab this little piece here on the
side
yeah that's basically it so let's just
copy this into the Squidward House model
paste it
it should just be inside of the house
bring it forward
scale it up
and I'll just get rid of these excess
pieces here
and then finally we have our little
portholes so that'd be glass and steel
but it's basically just tubes so we'll
spawn one tube bring it up rotate it 90
degrees and for those of you guys still
following along we are making a little
Squidward house for an underwater scene
that we have loaded up in another window
and we're almost done with the Squidward
Hut and we'll be dropping it in
momentarily so stand by let's uh let's
see let's just bring our reference out
to the side here then we can start
positioning these eyeballs
and let's definitely add some height to
these guys well kind of popping out but
I guess that's kind of how it's done
yeah maybe let's rotate these a little
bit in yeah okay
let's select both of those let's
rotational segments 50 let's give it
some height segments and some cap
segments so we have some geometry to
work with when we want to add a little
bit of detail to this thing
let's give it a fill it here of maybe
two segments maybe three segments two
centimeters that feels good to me and
then finally let's select each one of
these guys hold down ctrl and then hold
down the primitives button and let's
make a disk and that will actually spawn
it right on the cylinder or the tube or
any object you really you know and it'll
put it in the right orientation right so
we'll do the same for this other one
over here well select the tube hold
control and spawn a disk bring it
forward scale it down boom scoobert
house done okay
so what do we do now
it's actually scale up the door
all right sweet okay so now we need to
texture this thing it's definitely like
a rocky texture this is great okay let's
get rid of let's get rid of our
reference here and the figure and let's
just drop all of let's drop everything
under one group here call it Squidward
house and we know we want let's see that
would be ear I'm just gonna name all
this stuff
this is nose other ear this is the just
call that house we have our door which
is already textured both of these discs
would be windows and the tubes would be
portholes awesome so let's group the
windows as one group and then let's
group the house the nose and the ear in
another group and the door will just
stand alone so okay let's texture this
thing real quick here so we want it to
be a mossy kind of run-down look but
first we need the base look let's let's
see what we have on the old mega scans
we'll just search for rock we want
surfaces ooh
coal interesting um so it's kind of like
a dark dark rock but it's broken down
and dilapidated and whatnot right hmm
salt mine wall interesting or something
like this yeah this isn't bad
Icelandic mossy Rock
Wow that's crazy um lava stone
interesting interesting let's try uh
where was it this mossy rock Icelandic
mossy rock let's download this it's a
nice crunchy texture there
so for those of you guys hopping into
the stream we're at an all-time high we
got 191 people watching her now
basically we're doing a an underwater
scene and we are texturing a squid
birdhouse right now
to drop into our underwater scene which
we have pulled up in another tab and
once this is textured we'll wrap it up
and do the final touches on our scene
make it look real nice I appreciate you
guys for joining and staying in here
guys I know this is a long stream and I
know some of you guys don't even have
cinema 4d so it does mean a lot that you
guys are sticking in here this is
awesome this is very very cool very fun
for me so I really appreciate you guys
okay we're still downloading all right
cool that's still going in the meantime
what can we do
yeah let's get the windows so part of me
feels like we can just make these things
like chromed out sphere or chromed out
little planes here and then the these
portholes we can just make like a
dilapidated metal or uh like a kind of a
gross steel so I'm actually gonna use
the grayscale gorilla everyday materials
pack I use it a whole bunch and it's a
very quick way to texture your stuff so
yeah I'm gonna use the live DB viewer
and octane for that and see what we can
find here
and this was made by the man himself
Chad Ashley he is incredibly talented we
got some rusted metal here I think some
rusted metal would look really really
nice
let's do that let's download that and
then I wonder if there's like a moss we
could do here as well so like um
organics yeah we have grass it's not
really grass we're looking for I guess
it's more of a well maybe that would
work for what we're going for
let's just try it
grass in grass for why not let's
download that and then if there's
anything under concrete we might be able
to get an interesting Rock texture no
would it be under organic still
it is all good we are going to move on
here because I do have to be out of here
in about 20 minutes so let's see let's
see let's drop this rusted material on
the eyes that looks awesome
already yeah that looks great and then
let's load up that rock material we just
downloaded from mega scans and drop that
on to the Squidward house okay let's see
let's see let's make a new material
glossy material let's go into here and
start dropping those those images we got
a roughness normal color and
displacement will want the displacement
for this one as well so we'll drop those
in so we have our color let's do that
ooh very nice very nice let's drop our
roughness and that's going to change the
reflection yep let's drop our normal
that's gonna give us a lot of detail
here yeah and obviously you can see that
the way everything is the way the
texture is distributed it doesn't look
right but we'll fix that and let's make
a little displacement node here and
we'll set the height to 0.1 and then the
mid level to 0.5 and the level of detail
to 8k we'll drop that in and let's just
make let's get our let's get this
material looking right first so I'm
going to save this let's click on this
material here let's set it to so it's a
cubic
we should see it update in here
maybe I have to rerender the scene
there you go sorry it looks a ton better
and let's now mess with the displacement
so we'll set the height to ten it looks
pretty cool definitely looks old and
gross for some reason it's getting no no
we're good yeah there's the door so this
is more of like a bluish color so let's
hop in here go to the node editor let's
go to our diffuse image here and let's
drop in a color correction node and
let's just change the hue of this thing
yeah already that looks better it makes
the door pop a lot more to sweet
and then finally I think we're gonna
just do a quick mix material on the rock
and we want to give basically everything
on the top here we want to give it some
moss so let's go into how are we gonna
do this
yeah well make a mix material and we'll
drop our rock and we'll drop our grass
into that and then we'll drop that onto
the house so it's mixing both of those
together the mix material needs to be
set to cubic as well let's go in here
and right now it's being split up
fifty-fifty we don't want that we
basically want to put it in specific
areas of the texture here so it could be
in the corners or it could be just on
the top let's see what on the top looks
like so I'm gonna grab a fall-off node
drop drop that into the amount and set
that to let's see here we'll set that
mode to 90 degree so now everything
basically you have one texture just on
the top parts in the model and the other
texture everywhere else all right so
that looks pretty interesting it's
certainly hitting the nose a little bit
but I think that's okay let's try
something else let's do so we have that
right we have our fall off we might come
up be combining these at the end of the
day and then let's throw a dirt on there
as well and the dirt let's set the
strength to ten let's set the radius to
20 and you can see how the moss is kind
of growing inside cracks and crevices
we'll set that to a hundred
let's try inverting it so it's just on
the edges which doesn't look quite right
so
back radius maybe 50 tolerance we can
leave about the same the details yeah
we'll leave that about the same as well
let's basically see if we can't crunch
this down a little bit so I'm gonna drop
a gradient into there and just kind of
crunch these settings or rather we want
to basically break up this dirt node
here so I'm gonna do that with noise
let's drop the noise into the amount set
the projection to box set the contrast
to 100 so we can see what we're doing
we're gonna scale up the noise let's go
to 3 and then let's set the octaves to 8
and the Omega to 1 it's gonna give us
more detail into that and that's how we
want to basically break up the dirt node
so I'm going to use an ad or no I take
that back I believe it's a multiply so
dirt goes into 1 noise goes into the
other and you drop that into the amount
well that mixes everything together but
that's actually not bad
so I'm gonna save that and basically do
Oh also you guys will notice the
displacement is gone so let's take the
displacement node from the rock texture
and drop it into the mixed material and
that should bring it back yep but now
it's all mossy I think it's the dirt
node we just need to change the settings
on that radius maybe 20
oh I see I see so there's a lot more
crevices and cracks and I think it's
just using the displacement to bring in
those crevices and cracks and stuff so
I'm gonna take this dirt node here and
combine it with this fall-off map here
so that's going to be through a multiply
node so what both of those going in to
the amount and it's like super mossy and
we want to do the same for those
portholes so I might honestly just take
the same material and drag that onto the
windows
nice that's seen a lot of time down at
the bottom of the ocean perfect all
right let's keep moving we are closing
in on the end of this thing here so I
might tweak the eyes in a minute
also we're still getting this error here
where the door it's not quite working
but yeah there it goes so I feel like
technically there'd be moss on the door
as well and the windows but we'll see
here let's copy the squirt house and
paste it into our our underwater scene
and see what this looks like everybody's
still hanging in I know it's been about
two and a half hours now I really do
feel like I'm just rambling to myself by
the end of this thing so hopefully
everyone's good total everyone's still
following along
all right the house made it
it made it underwater here so we need to
adjust our light a little bit we'll
bring out we'll bring it up scale it up
and let's take the square root house and
just kind of rotate it off axis a bit
here
you
this is so ridiculous
I look so creepy that's awesome
that's super-creepy actually so I just
want to brighten things up and make sure
that we can actually see what's going on
here guys
so I definitely feel like this is the
beginning of this image it's gonna take
I think a bit more lighting it's going
to take
I'd like to scatter some stuff on the
ground like some rocks and some see you
eating kelp and whatnot I think the eyes
are a bit too reflective certainly so we
can pull that down a bit so officially
this is official
Sponge Bob cannon here I want to make I
certainly want to make the the house
seem a bit more broken down
maybe the ice being that reflective is
actually pretty sweet
let's maybe see if we can't get another
octane light off to the side here
this will just be a white light
maybe the fog is a bit too thick right
now but crank up the scattering phase
and see if that helps anything I think
that just scatters the light a bit more
so maybe what I'll do here what I'll do
here is have one part of the fog
actually be in the foreground that is
not as intense so like point one and
then I'll control drag it back into the
background and try to set that to point
to see if that does anything and I'll
just do a render region for just a
little strip here
so this will help actually if we can see
let's see there we go
there's our fog let's crunch it down and
just put it behind the Squidward house
and we want this fog to be a bit thicker
so it's looking a little bright so our
side line might be a little intense top
light can come down a little bit
and let's give it a little bit of fill
light here from the front so let's make
a new octane light this will be our fill
light back it off just a little bit turn
off the visibility
this is so ridiculous definitely add
some vignette but we'll probably do a
bit more of that in post
what's up Garrett welcome we're doing a
little ocean scene here I'm still
tweaking this thing like crazy it's
gonna take a few more hours but
unfortunately we have to leave in a
couple minutes here but yeah I'm just
got to keep plugging away this thing
keep tweaking the lighting very tedious
stuff maybe some boring stuff I don't
know I don't know maybe you guys be down
for that who knows but I definitely want
to scatter some some coral on the ground
as well maybe a little bit of depth of
field on this thing
and just a couple more things to make it
feel underwater and a couple more things
to make the house itself feel a bit more
like broken so I may I might break a
piece of the ear off or something I
don't know yet maybe the nose too but I
do like the the reflectivity of the eyes
I think that that feels cool to me
definitely add some fish and some
floating particles or something and
figured its you said when I make stuff
and c4d do I add film grain as a layer
like I'm blending with actual footage
and I do actually yeah once everything's
done and rendered I go into Photoshop
and do final tweaks there and add some
film grain to give it you know make it
feel like I was actually there I try to
make this stuff as photo-real as
possible
so yeah that's certainly kind of my
style with these renders I know everyone
has their their style and you guys
should certainly find your style I'm
still finding mine but yeah at least I
know that I I'm trying to go for photo
realism I'm adding film grain to this
stuff you know you know if you guys
follow me on instagram you'll see I like
add the white border and everything to
make it
feel like you know like a nice a nice
framed image or something but it's about
all the time we have today these things
have they could just get longer and
longer and longer and you know I wish I
could bring this thing to completion
right now with you guys but yeah yeah
and I hope you guys learned some stuff
doing this and I hope you guys are still
working on your scene as well your
underwater scene I can't wait to see
what you guys do the discord has been
updated thanks to sediment a made him a
moderator and yeah it's gonna be a lot
more organized for you guys so if you
hadn't already please join the discord
channel the link to that is in the
description of this video and if you
guys are looking for a fun way to to
help me out here or give back I do have
a website
I always feel awkward bringing this
stuff up but hey you know you guys got
to know about the website because I'm
excited about it like a coolest looks
I've got all my images and photography
here from around the world shooting film
some digital as well and I got the
little collections tab here free
shipping on orders over here bucks we
ship worldwide international and we try
to get the the prices down as cheap as
possible but I sign it give some music
recommendations write a little note on
the back send it to you guys usually
within a week or two but what I really
want to do is start posting some VFX
assets I know like the photography stuff
is not quite connected with this with
the renders and whatnot so I would love
to do some sort of like VFX pack for you
guys or some texture pack for you guys
something a little cheaper I know 40
bucks is a little expensive for for most
people for for an image but you know
it's basically all I have at this point
but I really do appreciate you guys
joining
thank you so much give this video a
thumbs up and a like leave a comment
down below let me know what you liked
about this let me know what you didn't
like about this what we could do better
next time and the discord is also a good
place for that as well so yes next week
fingers crossed
Ren will be coming over and we'll be
taking we'll be making a boss town
dynamics scene from scratch for you guys
we're going to apply the robot to mocap
data we're going to light the scene
we're going to do some 3d motion
tracking we're gonna render it and then
Ren is going to composite it we're gonna
make an HDR eye as well we'll bring it
from start to finish for you guys next
week that one might go on it I'll
probably be like noon to three noon to
four but we'll see we'll see how how
long that takes we want to keep it
reasonable you know but yeah thanks for
joining guys I really appreciate you and
I'll see everybody next week hopefully
with Ren by my side here and y'all stay
safe stay healthy I'll see you guys next
week
peace